так давання мабуть не число частий нам і
вид бувало з пішому класі для ви підкоп
відрахування з числами porsche притирання
два три чотири п'ять томів іншому класі
до фінішу спочатку про проти ти ціль
прийом для випадки fob числі не самий
числами піші притирання а потім перенести
його на випадки суспільстві світ числа
метрові притирання 6 7 8 9
якщо опалювання вченим та прийом віддавання
адже це не маніяк чисел частини нами в
переходом через розряд з але та чоловіка
лист в результаті аналізу виконуваних
день пізнаємо і ти вже не в спину ґрунтом
прийому так і ваня частини нами правилам до
дування суми до числа
складання йому увагу учнiв на ted ще заміні
вчи інший дуданів суму двох чисел ми
фактично дай йому сума до числа ярду
даємо і суму до числа такого числа
облік дадаєва 1 до даних суми а потім
до одержимого результату дадаєва інший
біда нок
аналогічно водиться право на вигляд.
суми вид числа доступний прийому pci
саня я кайми переносом ууу нову
ситуацію так і ваня писав написали пару
основного закону так давай дуже поспішаємо про
класі
так дай вчить числа інше притирання
вдавалася адаб і розставлення до Данки
забув ви знову
дружини озвучи над меншою кількістю та так го
тобіш і
треба переставши це дані перенесення емоцій
прийом на випадки додування з переходом
через розряд
під'їзну моду давання джастином і
вимагають у переставляли до данків
на жаль під як коли до меншого числа до
дають більш доступний прийом
уваги як і ми переносом ууу нову
ситуацію
адже увага на піт стали взаємозв'язок q
арифметичних день до давання та
уваги дуже і в першому класі пізнаємо
зі сцен взаємозв'язок кому я ще вид суми
двох чисел видно ти один так та ну хто
завищується
інший туди
тому на етапі підготовки а хто лізу йому
ведений вже ним спосіб мірку ваня magic
10 наприклад
види років чи дня ти знаєш його на дівчат
подаємо а у вигляди сум з ручних до
Данки також води з них до ревнивого вигляду
на q7
c2 листів яка ще вид суми двох з і ми
адже дня ти інший та так максим то зал і
шиться пише про це 2 сотні всього
прийому відома вчимося з першого класу від
ж
на етапі актуалізації опорних знань
способі в день до сильно а хто ліза
ватою ведений вже ним прийом адже уваги
для випадки
в числах magic 10 і внесок чесал
іншу десятку за хвилин числа суму з
ручних туди mkiv дізнаємося нині з прийомом
адже уваги на підставі взаємозв'язок q
арифметичних дейда дування і адже
уваги для випадки з переходом через
розряд
адже буває то шляхом перенесення веденого
способу мірку ваня в нову ситуацію
дуже і пояснювати як вид 10 дня ти дівчат
засовують чим можна світ кого ти так
сама призводи дні манії числа девід вигляд 14
прийомів числами ґрунтується на
взаємозв'язок арифметичних видів давання
уваги для його реалізації вже знімаються
у мід та заміні вати числа суму з
ручних до Данки то не мат і вагою і
відпочинок до Данки
адже доступний прийом уваги легким ми
знаємо йому вже не вправи ви в чині увагу
числа з переходом через розряд major 20
прийом увагу на pets таві провалу
не манить she славить суми на етапі
підготовкою а хто лізу йому правило так
ваня суми до числа тієї ж уваги
адже суми числа пропану та наукового
закінчать і розрізання пояснюй в і
конова тижня такий спосіб вже не
відкривають праворуч ловити до уваги числа
вид суми
узнаємо лінивцем прийомом числами вид
буваєте в
результати виконання системи початкових
задами вже не спочатку виконують завдання
засовую чиї права ловити уваги
числа вид суми
вона нас тут нам укрийте засовують щупа
передні завдання даємо важливі новини про
якщо ти значенням пропанованих вій
оскільки
менше ван і можна замінити і одні нею з
поданих в шукаю сун повідомлень завдання дару
нижчою розв'язаного
аналізу і чувaк він його не і вже ним ідеї
і часто передніх суспільстві формулі йому
суть прийому про числа на основі правил
обідні маніяк числа вид суми за значимо
то еротичну основу даного прийому птахів
мене али 4 на молитви магате вигляд усіх
уточнивши форму ливанця його провалу
дістати не його розуміння застосування про
чистий c прийом грунтується на заміні 2
цифрового числа суми розрядних до
данків то на вміння не мотати число
вид суми на етапі прав іншого
закріплення всі склади в ідеї пром
є вже не ми в голос і фіксуються
у розпал даному запасі, наприклад 5 14
дня ти сісти за меншого на 14 подаємо
виглядають суми розрядних до дані в 10 і
4 особою та 10 4 піднімаємо 66 піднімається
10 і одержима 4 до 4 до даємо ще чотири
видалити подрібненого
мого висить таблиці так і ваня то ж
до уваги дають грн у чоловіка звістка до
сліди зал та життя значення суми безміни
від нових до Данки
значення ризниці без зміни з меншого
нова без зміни білизни до тес особистості
та теоретичну основу та прийому
округлими посагами не це ж увага
прийому кругла ґрунтується на розумі
вже neff так пам'ятаю ось і числа до 10 так
давай ти ж не мати число 10 туди вати
одна цифра в число видно мати одну
цифрове число тома на етапі підготовки
до сильно по 30 ватів і вже нікуди повний
не читав до 10 на етапі дізнаємося про
треба пе-2 з ти дуже чекаю їстівну
того
у випад як із переходом через розряд
задавати це мабуть ти число 10 означає
але легше лише одна цифра в число
засовується і випадуть для числа
наприклад до трьох до дою і 9 інший до
до ніг 9 замінимо і близьким круглим
числом 10 до 3 до давати вам про 10
Деви масть на скільки бий шубу дому так
так вати на один не моя кельми ж
день із загальною шлю йому до трьох та дай йому
десять буде 13 або 13 мабуть і молоді
нбу до 12 адже 14 видно ти 7
вів'єн exim за мінімум близьким круглим
числом 10 адже 14 піднімаємо одесі
та й у масть на скільки бив буду ми
бачимо а ти на три томи набридло прання ж
день із загальної схема 14 мінус 10 буде 4
і до чотирьох до даємо а3 одержима 73 база
значить ще прийому цілий день не їв
універсальним прийомом про числа вага
засовується вище у випад коли та ваня
таві увага 6 7 8 9
чисел ці близькі до 10 у результаті
аналізу владної діяльності
з розв'язання за далечінь на суспільство не
прийомом округлими
дуже і ви означає по слідів кількох
помер кого не треба за значить ще в тілі
пік бується вище пізнаємо його не з
прийомом округлими ализами чаянів на
тему це педики вже не може сміливо шию
манту вати в icon його не ідеї акар
остигають тис від пам'ятки та й викладати
і про числа alloy with cell учинив
класу ми не можемо осередкові магати
показую прак
за провального виганяти його прийомів
числами в possible круглими відстояною у
будь-який нижчий для більшої частини не класу
але це буде зведенням колу і вже не будуть
бідного доз виду у його застосування
спочатку ви ж 20 а потім magic став
таким шину
так та ваня на magic 20 викладати а
двома способами частими нами та округленням
за божа ним врахувавши у випад куди даючи
більшого числа довершила дадан kuyper
залишають місцями, а до уваги
magic 20 виконується трохи ірма способом
і часті ми написали взаємозв'язок кори
у метричних біда дування ж уваги
написали правило піднімання числа
суми та шляхом округлими об'ємний до
таким чином з вас і розгорнув і прийоми
громадські працівники викурюються в magic
20 вигадування і увага дякую за
увагу